he's kind of a neutral observer in all
of this so because of that did you maybe
not do as much research so everyone else
you could be a little bit more surprised
there was a lot of things that I needed
to research actually going into it and
one was how to function 1970s camera
equipment because because initially they
had me in like this big body like almost
sort of astronomical sort of gear and I
was like we're gonna be running around
this house how am I gonna be like
manipulating this and taking it putting
it down and blah blah blah so we've kind
of worked on that initially and kind of
found the smallest camera that we could
that would kind of still be reasonable
and you know I had to look learn how to
cut film reel on a 1970s editing board
and yeah I mean it proved very difficult
I have to say but you know I didn't
necessarily research these the real
events that this I did I did my fair
share I didn't want to divulge too much
didn't want it to affect me in any way
it's not actually that scary making a
scary film so you know how much of a
laugh did you guys have probably too
much I mean we basically we're trying so
hard not to laugh in a lot of moments
because as you can imagine you get to
know each other in a very small intimate
cast and we got to know each other a bit
too well to the point where every time
you turn around and see someone's scared
face it was a little spooky you know it
was a little like overwhelming and a
little strange and why is he got that is
he grimacing is he smiling at me no I
don't always doing but and then also
that we had an amazing director but I
can't I can't say the same
his voice vocal sound effects you know
because obviously there's no music
there's no sound effects like in the
final cut which adds to the suspense
adds to the attention no no we just add
a director who decays you scream scream
these obscure stage directions or like
creaky stairs what can we just have a
guy who walked down the stairs
I don't know but it was great fun it
really was in a sense they are there was
a lot to kind of go through it is a guy
who is a non believer in the
supernatural but at the same time he's
very curious about it which is exactly
the same as how I feel about it you know
I I don't not believe in ghosts and set
what said supernatural beings but you
know I'm intrigued and interested in
people that have had experiences with
them and like you know I hope to one day
find out more and I I'm not saying that
I want a ghost to come and haunt me but
I think you know I think there's a lot
out there that we still don't know and
it's exciting what I love about films
set in the era is that it's a very
simplistic technology very minimalistic
in that sense they can't get their
mobile phones out and have no bars on
their you know reception it's it's it's
very raw and they're very believable
characters I think it's a it's sort of
embedded in a very very true true
reality and the fact that this is a true
story well true based on true events
sorry makes it all that more exciting
it's a very jumpy film and I have to say
that the jumps begin early and they end
at the end you know it's it's nonstop so
it's exciting this time obviously
looking forward to seeing the quiet ones
our fans out there watching us they're
also very much looking forward to
hanging again how much more can we look
forward to a Phoenix back story in
mocking shape I mean for those of the
people listening and watching or
whatever that for those of them have
read the book something that they'll be
well aware it definitely for people who
have seen Catching Fire again it
obviously leaves it in a very very sad
place and upsetting place
he's lost his wife he doesn't know where
she think yeah it's it start it starts
in a very distressing place for him at
the beginning of Mockingjay and I'd want
to spoil too much for those people who
haven't read or seen anything so far so
yeah it just goes on a hellish journey
and they all do and that's what I mean
that's what's so fantastic about the
books they follow these characters over
time and
a very difficult time that they were
living through filming been going in
Atlanta north moving on to Paris and
Berlin Atlanta is good and very much
looking forward to being close to the
home I have to admit but also I've never
really had the opportunity to explore
Paris and/or Berlin so you know one of
the wait-and-see looking forward to
saying it's a mine also the quiet ones
good lever that much thank you so much
you